BILL COSBY WAS
ONE OF MY IDOLS I WENT TO
HOWARD UNIVERSITY, HISTORICALLY
BLACK COLLEGE IN WASHINGTON,
DC, THERE LARGELY BECAUSE OF A
SHOW CALLED A DIFFERENT WORLD
WHICH WAS THE PRODUCT OF BILL
COSBY'S GENIUS AND HIS
INVESTMENT IN BLACK COLLEGES.
I WENT TO WATCH COSBY SPEAK WHEN
I WAS A SOPHOMORE AND HE SAT
THERE AND TOLD US WE WEREN'T
GOOD ENOUGH AND WE NEEDED TO
PULL OUR PANTS UP AND I STILL
WAS NOT WILLING TO SHAKE THIS
IDEA OF MY GREAT HERO WHO WAS
THE REASON I AM A FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE GRADUATE.
I AM HERE BECAUSE OF YOU I AM
SUPPOSED TO GROW UP AND BE A
HUCKSTABLE, RIGHT? HAVE THE
PERFECT HUSBAND AND PERFECT
BROWNSTONE IN BROOKLYN AND AT
THIS POINT IN LIFE I AM A SINGLE
MOTHER AND I ENDED UP BEING A
SINGLE MOTHER ALMOST TWO YEARS
AGO, FAILED RELATIONSHIP, THESE
THINGS HAPPEN.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT FAILED
RELATIONSHIP
>> BUT WHEN THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
FIRST UNFOLDED AND I REALIZED I
WILL BE A COPARENT AND NOT
CLAIRE HUCKSTABLE I THOUGHT I
LET THIS MAN AND THIS IDEA HE
CREATED DOWN.
>> Larry: YOU FELT LECTURED BY
HIM.
>> I FELT LECTURED BY HIM AND
NOW I'M LIKE, HOLD ON, HOMEY
WHAT WERE YOU DOING WHEN YOU
WERE TELLING
PEOPLE LIKE MY PARENTS AND
TELLING ME, WHEN YOU WERE
TELLING YOUNG BLACK THEN THAT
ARE PROTESTING IN THE STREETS OF
FERGUSON WHO HAVE THEIR PANTS
DOWN BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THEY DO
AND THAT'S HOW THEY DRESS , THAT
WE WEREN'T GOOD ENOUGH.
>> I GET THE HYPOCRISY THAT
PEOPLE FEEL, BUT TO ME IT IS A
SIMPLE CASE OF HERE IS A FAMOUS
GUY WHO PEOPLE PROTECTED AND
BECAUSE OF HIS FAME NOBODY
WANTED TO BELIEVE IT.